[Applause]
thank you guys gonna be here thank you
for staying West Virginia [ __ ] those
guys in East Virginia am i right
in other words Chuck trust me I know
what it's like I'm from South Korea
we have shitty neighbors too oh my god
North Korea they're the worst
I am a Hans Kim it's my real name people
think it's a stage name it's not I
wasn't like how do I get audiences think
about North Korea and the Nazis well I
performed comedy my parents sent me Hans
because they didn't want to get this
school to make fun of me for having an
Asian name so they gave me a German one
it's dead and it's right under the radar
they had no idea was Asian great planned
parents you know I have a funny name but
they could even funnier that Tanner is a
white person saying I know that what you
white [ __ ] they should be like
hey this is my Mexican friend tanner
that's my black friend tannest nothing
sure I am Asian or is it nose country
I'm Chinese
I'm from a Province in China called
South Korea I love that place represent
I'm Asian by the way I love being Asian
except when people make fun of us for
eating dogs that kind of hurts my
feelings but I understand because in
America dogs are treated like family
members but in Asia we have this weird
honor tradition where we treat our
family members like family members
instead of buying an animal we love our
grandma
unless she's a baby girl which case you
throw in the river it must be done one
trial only let's try now love being
Asian I think China gets a bad rap you
know everyone's like oh they're morally
reprehensible but so is America okay
West Virginia why are you looking at me
like that I love America now China is
pretty bad but what do you think is more
likely that and a hundred years that
we're gonna stop invading foreign
countries or that Google or that China's
gonna let you Google [ __ ] what do you
think is more likely to have it China
Google Inc letting you google [ __ ] it's
that that's your funny punchline damn it
I [ __ ] it up
what's Virginia you win your mega energy
over there just kidding you guys like
super liberal Hillary Clinton all the
way right that's right all right never
mind I am I do believe in a universal
basic income you know I'm a super lefty
I think the universal basic income is
great I think if everyone got a thousand
dollars a month you guys would be a lot
more bearable to be around I I don't
understand all these middle managers and
CEOs like how am I supposed to motivate
my employees if I can't threaten them
with death you mean if I want people to
work for my company I have to have a
company people want to work for what
without a weak person trying to do
something evil what about the
protections for me said Jeff Bezos okay
capitalism is fine if you want to do it
but don't make everyone play your stupid
game
I like Starcraft 2 I don't make your
grandma play and take away our house if
she loses all right let's get off of
Facebook join the Instagram world and
happiness
infinity so I'm single all that all
right everyone's got a mate everyone's
made it up like I looks like Haley Joel
Osment
hi I am single I like Haley Joel Osment
skinny beautiful Haley Joel Osment how
did you last minutes back you enough he
is you're not Wow beautiful beard so I
don't have a beard
I'm Asian like I said it's hard date as
an Asian man you know everyone things
agent women are beautiful not everyone
thinks Asian men are beautiful which
doesn't even make any sense because how
do you think Asian women are created me
[ __ ] I'm a crucial part of the sexy
process please stop trying to skip me if
you have sex with me or children will be
very beautiful half of it the other half
will be great engineers and that's
important to you I don't understand
rednecks you know because they can
survive in any wilderness situation that
you put them in except a situation where
everyone has equal rights I kind of
[ __ ] them up you can live in a swamp
with an alligator why can't you live in
a colder side with a minority figure it
out have you tried smiling I don't
understand these people who played
immigrants for all their problems are
like you know it's taking all my money
the people with less money than me
they've got my money what about the
people with the money maybe they took
your money cuz they have it now the
people without it cuz they don't have it
I'm an immigrant I'm pretty good at math
Oh God I I love you know being single I
used to date a woman who is real
to yoga and choke sex and I was like do
you enjoy breathing or not make up your
mind millenials i i i don't i don't date
around too much anymore you know
i I am an ex who kept giving me dating
advice and I she was a real feminist she
was like concerned or whatever and she
kept trying to tell me how did how to
have sex and I was like I don't take sex
advice from a gender that can't even
come during sex premature to who
I can't wait at the perfect time when I
felt amazing takes maturity to know how
to please yourself
and I placed myself all the time
sometimes a little too early but at
least I got there you know not like you
I win first place
III don't think I could have ever had
sex with a dude's sorry fellas I've
never looked at a beautiful woman and I
was like wow she's gorgeous but is there
a version of her that's bigger and
hairier and has less kindness I'm honest
think that on my butthole never happened
straight as [ __ ] my friend was like dude
were so lucky when I gay can you imagine
if most of the gender you were attracted
to wasn't attracted to you back and I
was like whoa can't even imagine
they must play all the time those other
people that are nice bunch of losers I
don't understand homophobia they'll be
like it's Adam and Eve not Adam and
Steve but Adam and Eve weren't even a
good couple in the Bible first of all
they disobeyed God and ate a fruit they
weren't supposed to eat which is kind of
gay
and then they raised Cain and Abel and
Cain murdered Abel why are we taking
parenting advice from people who raised
a murderer
there are only three other people on
earth they killed a quarter of the
world's population here your [ __ ]
together your startup I I don't
understand racism I think the Black
Panther movie was great because it gave
black children a hero they could finally
look up to not just someone like Martin
Luther King jr. or Rosa Parks or Harriet
Tubman and Nelson Mandela or Kofi Anan
that's it I'm Michael Jordan
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat good for them they finally
made it
where's our movie huh where's it where's
the hungry panda we've got a movie for
us I am NOT a racist
of course I I hate people too I just get
to know them first so you need people
for their skin I hate people for their
souls but I was on an airplane once and
I saw a dude reading a book in Arabic
which kind of freaked me out but then I
saw him pull the corner of the page it
put his book away and I was like oh
thank god he's got future plans not a
racist I'm excited for the Little
Mermaid movie coming out did you hear
that she's gonna be the first Disney
princess to wear a shower cap for most
of the movie but she led me to that sure
I am a racist I'm a bad person
I'm not a bad person I think it's funny
that sometimes I socialize with women
and they say ridiculous things to me
like this one lady she was like did you
know that my vagina is a 3d printer and
I was like that is technically incorrect
thank you
your room is a 3d printer your vagina is
the Train it's not even a very good 3d
printer who prints one thing with lots
of errors takes nine months to print and
the whole time is printing it's
complainings not a great 3d printer
I did not say any trades that night the
trayless night for me but it is going
fine I am single like I said I have yet
to meet my soul mate I'm beginning to
think maybe it's her fault she needs a
good alcohol she seems like a loser I
think I could do better
all right that's my time there you guys
very much good night